am 30 juni 2016 tritt rodrigo blut hatte
das amt als philippinische präsident an
er gelobt gegen drogen und drogendealer
in den krieg zu ziehen
wir haben drei millionen drogensüchtige
die ich gern abschlachten würde bis
heute kostet es krieg nach angelo
schätzungen annähernd 30.000 menschen
leben
damit gilt er als bis dato mörderisch
der drogenkrieg und wird international
scharf verurteilt
das problem bei außergerichtlichen
hinrichtungen ist man kann nie sicher
sein dass es die richtige zielperson
warum tun sie das
die bringen mich um wird dieser tödliche
krieg gegen die drogen die probleme auf
den philippinen lösen oder verschlimmert
er die misere der ärmsten der armen
[Musik]